Gemini這個新功能我們只能用這個來形容
他讓資料研究這件事情有了飛升一般的變化
以前你看到頭昏眼花的大量研究相關文字
現在只要一分鐘
Gemini立刻自我分析並且做出各種各式各樣不同情境的應用
在剛邁入2025下半年的此時Google又再次讓我們感受到AI的能力再次提升
再次爆表
嗨各位有所AJ deep research
深度研究這個詞 大家應該不陌生對吧
在四個月之前
我們拍了第一支關於Gemini產出這個深度研究的功能之後呢
陸續各家AI產品們都相繼推出了屬於自己的deep research
好反正就大家都做了
但有些敏銳的同學應該發現了在深度研究推出之後呢
好像這個功能就就好像差不多這樣沒有什麽比較亮眼的更新
最多也只有推出一些小小的比如說自定義參考檔案的一些小更新
雖然說這個功能看起來好像當初的雷聲大
最後好像變得有點雨點小
正當我們快要覺得哎呀可惜涼了的時候
Gemini冷不妨的推出了這個建立功能
簡單來說就是在你完成了一篇深度研究之後
現在他只要一鍵你就可以分別產出客製化的應用程式
包含網頁資訊圖表測驗甚至是語音摘要等等 必須說這個功能兩個字超讚
他重新定義了深度研究的玩法
讓深度研究的報告在Gemini里面就可以產出更大的價值
今天這集影片就讓我們帶著大家一起來實測這些新功能吧
開始之前快速的感謝時間
感謝接近60位的同學還有學長姐的會員加入
泛科學院如今的發展你們每一位的貢獻都功不可沒
如果沒有各位的話我現在就只能在公司打雜掃掃地了
接下來滿100人的時候呢
我們預計約辦一場感謝季的活動
大家可以留言告訴我們感謝季你想要怎麽樣過呢
另外還沒有加入的朋友一個月只要一趟Uber的費用就可以享有更多的優惠
趕緊一起加入我們的行列吧
在上機實做之前我先來 不算勘誤
就是來說一些名詞解釋
這也是我們最近出去上課的時候最常遇到的一個問題
Gemini 2.5有分成兩個模型啊第一個叫做Pro專業版模型
另外一個叫做flash
我可以把它叫做閃電模型
先給各位一個簡單的小知識補充到底什麽時候要選2.5Pro
什麽時候要選2.5 flash呢
說實話在深度研究了
我們今天在影片上用這兩個模型感受沒有那麽的明顯
但是我們用一個比較簡單的比喻
2.5 Pro你可以把它想象成是一個博士的研究生
他的特色是知識淵博
推理能力極強
思考會更加的深入
而且他能夠處理覆雜跟模糊的一些指令
他特別擅長多層次的分析跟一些綜合的整理歸納
那代價是什麽呢
代價就是需要更多的時間他會需要更多的思考時間
所以他從以下指令到他給你結果的這個時間會花的比較長一點
以及更高的研究經費
也就是這個API這個模型號使用成本較高
那當然Google對家大業大幫我們把這些賬單都付掉了
但是不管是在免費版的這個Gemini網頁版或者是付費版的Gemini網頁版
其實Gemini pro你比較不容易遇到
因為像現在Gemini進到比如說Google workspace 在gmail里面啦這些
大部分都是用flash模型
Gemini也知道Pro模型的成本是比較高的反應也是比較慢的
所以通常只有在比如像深度研究和這種
很特殊的一些使用的功能跟情境里面呢
他才會去選擇性的調用這一個專業版的模型
所以接下來各位其實比較常用到的是一個叫做Gemini 2.5 flash的模型
那這個flash模型你可以把它想象成是一個資優的大學生
它的特色就是反應很快
學習能力很強
能夠迅速抓起跟總結一些核心的資訊
執行明確的指令
而且效率極高
因為它的優勢就是速度快和且成本效益極高
在執行這些模型的時候呢
不管是用在Gmail啦或者Deep research啦
一般日常生活的提問回答好他都很快的就可以搞定你的工作
那當然有時候用起來可能會不如pro模型
因為他直接給你結果了
他不是先思考之後來給你結果的
所以你在使用的時候
最簡單的一個差別就是如果你在做程式碼生成當然盡量去選Pro模型
不過對一般使用者而言那就不會寫到程式碼
00:04:23,240 --> 00:04:27,320
那對工程師而言大家就會開始去評估我要用哪個模型來去做操作
總而言之就是你會日常生活就是使用flash模型就可以了
因為他非常的迅速而且回應的品質也不差
就我們自己的實測如果你是免費版的網頁的服務的話
其實他大概會給你5次到10次
那我不知道你看這是影片的時候那個額度有沒有變化
反正總之就是他會有一定的額度的使用次數的限制
好消息是呢
你在用的時候不管你是用Pro模型還是你是用flash模型去做Deep research
他都只扣一次而已哦 所以他不會像某些廠商還是用點數算沒有
他就是一次而已如果你沒有用過的話
我建議你可以有意識的去盡量的去選擇pro型來去做使用
雖然說會慢一點點
但是回答出來的品質有可能會超出你的想象
好了讓我們進來這個Gemini的這個操作畫面那我們選擇用這個2.5 Pro的模型
然後呢請幫我研究關於GROK4的相關資料GROK4這個禮拜剛出
所以呢你就跟這個Deep research說我要一個這個研究計劃開啟Deep research功能
然後就問你說要做哪些研究的方向
那就不用管他
好你就按開始研究
因為時間關系我們就已經先跑好了那他就會做一個研究出來
那看起來沒問題
右上角這邊現在
多了一個建立
建立里面有四種模式可以選擇那第一個我們就可以選網頁的模式
所以你可以觀察到現在Gemini的這個Deep research他只有在這個模式下有建立
所以如果你用一般的對話提問然後網絡搜索什麽的他是不會有建立的
我覺得有一點類似canvas的這樣那個概念
那但在Deep research這個結果之下他會給你更多的東西他去做內容的建立
他開始就是
搗鼓一些事情然後就開始生成網頁
那給他一點時間其實跑的蠻快的
有了沒問題啊爭奪AI霸豪賭
然後這邊你可以看到這個是預覽模式
當然你可以就直接按共用然後覆制內容
然後就可以出去給別人查閱
在這個模式之下他沒有像canvas模式的一個部屬成網頁的功能
但我覺得這功能應該只是還沒有做而已
所以我猜之後應該會實做
本質上其實就是把你剛剛找到的那份報告
變成是一個網頁的原始碼的形式去整理跟呈現
這個部分我覺得他的不管是這個圖表的制作
你看他的移上去都還會有顯示啊
然後他的分頁的這個設計 簡單做了一個一頁式的網頁
你就可以拿著這個原始碼去做後續的這些部署什麽
所以你可以觀察到我們剛剛生成這個網頁之後呢
後續他就幾乎就沒辦法再去做這個後續的生成
就比如說你要用提示語的方式
去要求他去改這個網頁啊
那或者是你要把網頁拉下來你要自己拿去改
但其實叫他改其實也是會動只是你就得開始去掃腦筋說
我想要怎麽改這個網頁
幹嘛幹嘛之類的我覺得他沒有提供一個比較像是一個
引導的這樣的一個功能是有點可惜但這邊先埋個梗
我們等一下會有一個有趣的新功能
這次的這個Gemini能做到的事情不止於此
比如說我們再回到剛剛的這個報告
那他在建立里面除了剛剛做了這個網頁的形態
我還可以請他做成資訊圖表的形態
所以我們這邊一樣就看了一下之後他就會開始生成程式碼
然後這次他是用互動式的圖表來去做呈現
那看起來也是用網頁元件的方式去畫
這部分跟那個Claude做成SVG的那種格式的邏輯其實有點像
不過他這個是直接生成網頁的形式
我們自己在測的時候在看的時候其實我覺得各有優劣
你真的要這張圖的話
你還是直接把它截圖下來放到你的簡報里面去可能會比較好用哦
那這邊其實我們在測試的時候有2點的心得可以跟各位分享
其實看起來也就是個網頁
重點是當初在deep research的時候你最好找的問題就要盡量包含一些數據
比如說你可以去做一些財報啦
跑分的比較啦
你要有一些數字
有數字他才能夠做圖表的分析圖表的制作那剛剛提到就是說如果你
當初下的Prompt沒有下的很明確啊
那你已經做出來了那你還想要來補救一下
當然我們可以透過提示語的方式來去要求他
比如說我就可以跟他說
請幫我針對各種數據來去做制作
附上詳細的文字說明在這邊做送出之後
那你會觀察到他的這個
資訊圖表
其實就網頁
他其實就會去再次的去搜尋一些相關的補充資料然後把那些東西放進來
然後重新的去制作你的這個互動式的網頁
你必須對於你要做的事情你要有足夠的想法啊靈感
那有了靈感跟想法之後Gemini ai
他就會去協助你去幫你做一些資料的補充
那這邊我們一樣可以觀察他開始思考
然後開始找一些相關的資料
他就開始重新調過這個版本的網頁
我提示你剛剛是叫他去找GBT o1的模型
結果呢他現在跑去找了這個4o的模型出來做比較
哎你自己故意挑了一個比較弱的對手
這樣不行
那原本我們這個報告當初一開始是在做GROK4的這個模型的研究跟分析
但是你把它加了其他模型進去他就會對應的去更新相關的這些東西
那你可以看到
他就開始有了一些其他圖表的一些比較呈現的方式
所以這個就是Gemini的網頁制作或者是叫做資訊圖表的功能
但這個功能做這個地方你會覺得說好像也就普通
這個功能我覺得最有趣的地方呢
比如說我們再去找一個測試的結果出來
比如說我們做Lovart之後
在建立里面一樣我們可以要求他去生成測驗或者是語音摘要
他就是Notebook LM
里面的那個語音摘要這個我覺得就也都大家快被做爛了那一樣
你可以下載啊什麽的
我覺得這個太簡單了哈
但我覺得最有趣的地方是呢你在這建立這個地方
你把它選擇用測驗這個模式
他直接幫我出成了這個測驗的題目
然後他直接幫我開始寫題目
而且題目看起來是越來越多啊
然後他還會給你一些提示
老師跟家長大喜現在AI幫你出題目
而且按一下你也不用學什麽寫提示語啊什麽有的沒的
但是我們自己測了一下之後發現 這個測驗會有一些小問題
第一個就是我們發現他的題目你看我根本沒讀我就按了就對了
他的答案呢通常都會是AB
就是你如果沒有特別去要求他的話呢
那出來的結果呢這個答案的話就是AB
好那我就隨便做了一下剛才那個題目
然後就隨便寫就對了7題我真的沒有看到就亂按一通啊
那接下來呢
接入來的這個測驗它里面有一個很有趣的小功能
Gemini在網頁里面
所以你會觀察到你自己去做實作的時候跑出來這個測驗
測驗結束之後呢
他會用Gemini模型讀你的答案
然後給你一個評比
所以他不是只給分數位
這個Google表單就可以做了
拿Gemini來做什麽事呢
這個測驗他有趣的地方是他直接幫你內建的一個Gemini的老師在里面
然後他會根據學生答題的結果
給一份分析報告
這個表現亮點還有需要加強的地方
這一塊是Gemini生成的動態生成
這就開啟了一個非常非常新的一個應用方式
以前我們叫Gemini生成的這些網頁啦生成這些內容啦
如果網頁內我要在內建一個AI
那就你還在下prompt什麽的
所以最近各家AI現在開始流行
就是我在AI生成的網頁里面直接內建AI模型的互動功能在里面
所以這個就是一個非常非常典型的一個案例
根據你回答的內容然後去評比然後就提出一些可以的修正的建議
就像是一個真的老師一樣
那當然老師們一定會現在開始先去研究說
這個他這個AI老師Gemini老師寫出來的這個評比到底
符不符合我的想象跟期待
當然你在做實做的網頁開發就是這個功能開發的時候
你可能也會需要在額外的去加上一些prompt去提醒他說
那個題目不可以這樣解釋
或者是怎麽樣 這個就留待老師們
大家開始會花時間去跟你的Gemini來當一個好朋友了 所以這個是Gemini
我覺得這一波這一次功能更新最重要的功能叫做測驗的功能
那當然測驗的這個結果做出來的這個線上互動測驗
你可能會覺得說話太無聊幹嘛
或者是你覺得還不夠
所以我就說
幫我好把測驗擴充到25題
題目要加上覆選題啊連連看啊
界面要增加一些設計感
加入CSS動畫
答案之後解題文字要更加詳盡
結尾的測驗要加入各種圖標統計跟分析
然後就送出要求他去做改進
除了模型內建在里面之外
一樣你可以通過提示語的方式去要求他去更加的完善你的這個網頁
說實話本次還是網頁設置
只是他在生成網頁的時候加上了一些提示語的巧思
然後讓你可以無腦的直接生成一個線上測驗這樣的一個互動的一個形式
那當然你可以再次的通過提示語的方式去要求他做出一個更加覆雜
更加美觀
更加符合你的小考需求的一個測驗
那這5個修改方向呢
就是我們這自己在測試的時候整理出來的歸納的一個結論啊
所以其實不代表官方的建議
所以各個老師如果你有在玩這個功能的話
我也會建議你可以去把你自己的一些東西加上去啊
或者是你可以故意放放一些你們手頭上有的一些題庫啊答案呢
或者是這個期中考要考的一些個單字的那個單字庫
我相信老師們應該手上都會有很多很多的這種參考資料
你可以把它丟上去
然後請Gemini針對你這次考試的內容然後先做一個類似模擬
考你就可以讓同學擁有更多考試練習的機會了
這個就是 不知道同學來說是好事還是壞事啊
那對老師來說一定是好事
不過話說回來因為他這個共用還沒有做出來
那我不禁就把他想起來就如果我今天去Google site
然後開一個site
然後把那個網頁放進去內簽
貼
下一個插入
會動了
好 發布
測試
所有公開
完成發布
哎
查看已發布的網站
所以手動做還是可以的嘛
好所以我覺得還不錯那程式碼
可能要稍微調一下這個看起來是會動的
所以你也可以用Google的這個協作平台然後把它生成程式碼
直接手動部署一下 沒有任何技術門檻
你就是按共用然後覆制
然後去協作平台然後放內簽
然後貼上然後就可以發布了
好所以其實也不用花你30秒時間
我覺得真的是還蠻方便的
好測驗完成然後呢
他一樣會給你整體表現的圖表
答對率 核心概念
功能特性工作流程用場景思想情況然後他會有錯誤回顧
做的真的是還不錯
最後我們一樣拿了Lovart這個案例來去做實做 那我們選建立啊
那最後呢我們用這個描述你要打造的應用程式那你也知道敝人頻道
最多人看的就是做簡報
請制作一個搭配插圖的詳細PPT簡報
他就可以幫你把Deepresearch找到這個結果呢
然後直接做成一個簡報的這個形式 那一樣他會花點時間去思考
然後最終還是用網頁去模擬簡報的方式去做一個實作 好了
Lovart深度解析重新定義設計流程的智能代理然後
他因為是簡報的形式
所以我可以按左右鍵去播放他
但是
一份簡報也沒有什麽了不起
了不起的地方是他在這個地方做了一個按鈕叫做新增Gemini功能
好比如說核心功能
我在這個地方按一下新增Gemini功能
這個按鈕超級隱晦的吧
躲在這個地方那這個按鈕來做什麽事情呢
他會試圖在你做的這個網頁那以我們這個案例來說是簡報里面呢
直接塞上一個Gemini來進去里面你就可以在這個網頁上
這個節目上去跟Gemini來做一些簡單的互動啊
你看他就是現在的兩項有Gemini的API驅動的全新互動功能
一個是AI方案推薦顧問一個是腦力激盪那所以呢
等他一下
所以他這邊又多了AI方案推薦顧問的功能這邊
好 我是一個Youtuber
要用哪個方案呢
取得推薦
你可以觀察到他就是用Gemini去回答你的提問
所以他就回答在網頁的這個結果
然後再根據Gemini的大腦然後再提供給一個回答
透過把Gemini裝到網頁里面去之後呢他就能夠提供回覆這件事情
那接下來我們就會想說
那他既然都可以生成文字
那我們是不是應該讓他生成個圖片試試看呢
沒錯所以我們今天的最後一個demo就是我可以要求直接啊請Gemini
來說一個屬於這個內容的圖像生成網站
直接要求他變成一個圖像生成網站那當然我就跟他說一只小的柯基正在吃
吃著爆米花
那這邊有一個強化我的想法
這邊就是專門來正在讀取你的初始的Prompt
幫你把Prompt寫的比較覆雜一點哦
就有你類似那個Gemini的GEM的那個功能
去強化你的提示語變得比較覆雜一點
我們觀察到一個很有趣的現象就是
他幫你選擇了這個Gemini imagen3還有Flux Pro跟GPT Image 1
那我先不動它我們按一下生成圖像
圖就出來了 但GPT Image 1
那不是要錢嗎
好所以我們來看一下程式碼
進去程式碼裡面 比如說我們在這個地方搜尋API
那還是說這個由Gemini api驅動嗎
那API kry他剛控在這個地方然後他會直接帶系統內建的API進去
這就導致了我剛剛把他程式碼複製出來之後
到了其他的比如說Google site的網站的時候
這個Gemini的這個API的請求是失敗的
你就必須要要求Gemini
請額外提供我一個輸入API的文字方框
這樣子你部署到其他地方的時候你就可以自己塞一些API進去
那當然你也可以再跟他講說請給我一個open AI的API key
或者是那個flux的API key的輸入框
然後按儲存之後去調用
open AI的這個API的模型來去做這樣的一個工作在他的這個環境之下
在他的這個預覽模式之下
他會提供給你一些最基本的這個api的使用功能去做到模型的調用
但是你把這個程式碼一但拿到其他地方去
你就得去傷腦筋怎麽樣去把這東西把它部署出來
那所以在這個情況之下你選了這個
GPT Image 1呢
實際上他還是會生成沒有錯
但是他其實就是用Google自己的模型去生圖片
假裝自己是GPT Image 1
以上就是這次的影片
不知道你對於這個Gemini的這個Deep research里面的
建立這個功能的感想是什麽
我自己看一看之後我覺得他是往好的方向
就是去真正的去切合我們實際上的工作
然後去做報告或者是你可以去做成測驗
或者是他也提供了一個自定提示語的功能讓你可以去做成簡報啦
或者是甚至是其他的這些各種各式各樣的功能
他因為他內建的這個Gemini AI模型在網頁里面他直接做到了
無痛打通後面的那個模型api的這個功能
那就導致了大家就開始瘋狂的玩耍
但是我們之前測應該veo3的影片API還沒有還沒有打通哦
那我不知道你看到這次影片的時候這功能有沒有成功
那如果你有成功直接在這個地方生成VEO3影片的話
麻煩在影片下面留言跟我們大家分享一下你自己的案例
那當然你把它裝到Google的協作平台或者是裝到你自己的一些
托管的網站的這些前端
那你也可以去做一些測試那接著影片就到這個地方
感謝各位的收看那我們下期影片再見嘍拜拜